if you're writing to figure out what you
think then you're going to use what you
think to guide your action and the
consequence of that is going to be how
your life turns out so I'm dead serious
about what I write because because I
know what the pathway is you don't
communicate in a false manner because if
you do you'll warp the structure that
guides your actions and you will
absolutely suffer for that I mean one of
the things I've learned as a clinical
psychologist is that I've never seen
anyone get away with anything let's say
you get away with something it's like
yeah you think so man you wait five
years from now seven years from now
it'll come back is that Karma it's more
like yes I think it's the same idea you
don't have the power to manipulate
reality like you have the power to bring
about reality in some sense because you
confront potential and through your
action and your communicative intent you
turn potential into reality so you don't
think Visionaries and influencers have
the ability to bend reality no I don't
think they bend it I mean you can bring
new things into being but you can't get
away with a falsehood and you can't get
away with weak thinking either because
any more than you can get away with
improper action it just doesn't work I
mean one of the the themes in my writing
is the danger of falsehood and at any at
every level it's like well if you tell
the truth to the degree that you can or
at least don't lie then you have reality
on your side you've got to decide you
want reality on your side or do you want
reality against you I wouldn't recommend
the whole reality against you thing
because you're not going to win you're
going to get flattened need motivation
watch your top 10 believe Nation hey
it's Evan Carmichael and I make these
videos because you are probably the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more and you get
that Push by surrounding yourself with
the best so today let's learn from one
of the best Jordan Peterson and my take
on his top 50 rules for Success enjoy
we are thrown
challenges and that they're that and
that in some sense those are best
construed as tests of our ethical
ability so what Jung thought his idea
was something like this that at the
beginning of time people were
unconscious and that Consciousness
emerged with all of its catastrophes
consciousness of death for example and
one way out of the burden of
Consciousness was to return to
unconsciousness you can do that with
alcohol you can do that by being
dependent you can do that by failing to
grow up you refuse the burden of
Consciousness by becoming unconscious
again but there's another way for it
which is to become even more conscious
so the idea would be a little bit of
Consciousness is like an illness but if
you can expand that Consciousness
upwards enough then it's some something
it starts to become something that it's
all that is its own cure and that partly
what your goal is while you suffer
through life is to heighten your
Consciousness to the point where
everything gets integrated enough so so
that that's proper medication for the
disease of self-consciousness that's one
thing to live properly and that's not a
trivial thing but it's another thing to
be to be able to articulate yourself and
to and to negotiate and and generally
speaking there's nothing about that that
isn't advantageous and even introverted
and anxious people can learn to do that
you know it's those are learnable skills
it's not easy but but but you can manage
it you can also
you can also speak carefully you know
and listen to what you're saying and
only try to say things that you think
are true that's also unbelievably useful
you have to feel that out like is this
really what I believe or am I putting it
Forward well because I want to look good
or I want to dominate or uh or I want to
express
obliquely an emotion that I'm too
cowardly to come out and confront
directly or am I being manipulative
there's lots of reasons that people use
language but what you really should use
it for is to State what you believe to
be true and then to let the consequences
of that unfold
and so that can also help you
simple truths
bluntly stated can be very powerful you
don't need a lot of verbal fluency under
those circumstances if there's evidence
of strength of character behind it look
it's good for you to go take your place
in the world have some ambition have
some have a vision have a goal have a
strategy try to try to be a good person
and not not because it's your duty
precisely because that's the proper way
to live we're in danger of undermining
all of that and it's not good for people
one of the things that I've really
learned for example recently is that
there's a or learn to articulate better
is that there's a very tight
relationship between aspiration and
responsibility so let's say well the
first question might be do you need to
Aspire to something and the answer is
well yes because you have to do
something okay if you just sit there
you'll die you can't just sit there you
have to go act out in the world okay so
act towards what well that's whatever
your aspiration is you have to have a
name okay well what should the aim be
well it should be something worth doing
let's say why do some something that you
don't feel is worth doing what do you
think's worth doing well if you watch
other people and you judge when they're
doing something worthwhile you usually
judge them positively if you see that
they're taking responsibility at least
for themselves or do you want to be
completely useless so other people have
to take care of you that's pretty
pathetic and maybe you could get your
act together so you're taking care of
yourself and your family and maybe you
could even do better than that and take
care of yourself and your family and
your community also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
there's lots of ways of defying the
crowd let's say I mean you could live
your life the way that you want to live
it that's a matter of action
you know and they say actions speak
louder than words and one of the best
things you could possibly be is uh
inspirational example so that's not
nothing
um
that's that's something live properly
in your Defiance of the crowd right
make your own course
allow yourself to be guided by your own
genuine principles you don't necessarily
have to advertise that which is in some
sense what you're doing when you when
you're debating because you're taking
the manner in which you act like if
you're an integrated person and you're
articulating that
um but maybe you can't do that because
you don't have the verbal skills well
then the question would be maybe you
should develop some more verbal skills
like I don't know this for sure Dave you
know but but generally it's useful how
do you do that
um
doesn't hurt to read
really doesn't hurt to write you know a
little bit of writing every day
clarifies your thinking you need a value
hierarchy it's inevitable that you have
a value hierarchy
and that you look at the world through
it and that it should be well structured
and that there should be something of
divine importance at the top I would say
what should occupy the top position is
the realization for example that each
person is of divine value and that the
most appropriate way of interacting with
potential is by embodying and speaking
the truth
that's not a bad way of
briefly conceptualizing what might be at
the highest Pinnacle of the value
structure I would say that's what the
logos is
and so
the soul is a
the soul is what manifests itself in the
choice between different pathways
in in the choice between different ways
of transforming the potential of the
future into the actuality of the present
and it does that
by making ethical Decisions by choosing
between good and evil at each choice
point and to the degree that it chooses
good then it takes the raw potential of
the future
and it transforms it into the being of
the present that is good and to the
degree that it does that in a manner
that's evil and contaminated by
malevolence and hatred and vengefulness
then it takes a pathway that corrupts
the world and makes things worse and
it's the soul that's doing that and it's
the soul that's responsible for that and
it's also that active part of the Soul
that's shaping
the deeper soul in some sense which
would be something like the cumulative
consequence of all those choices
something akin to what people
more classically have referred to as
character your life doesn't have meaning
without aspiration or name okay so you
need a hierarchy of values there's got
to be something at the top it's got to
be something important if you don't have
that your life doesn't have any meaning
so if you criticize the hierarchy or
even the ideas of idea of hierarchy you
destroy the idea of aspiration and then
people have nothing well that's not
helpful people are built for a struggle
and they're built for a weight and you
want to take on a heavy burden
voluntarily see if you can put yourself
together see what you can do out in the
world while you're waiting to die it's
an all-in game it better be worthwhile
and so there's a tight relationship
between responsibility and aspiration
and hierarchy and when you criticize
those things you get rid of the
aspiration you have to negotiate until
you come to the best solution that can
be negotiated which isn't necessarily a
perfect solution but it might be the
best one that can be done and then you
have to stick with it until the next
negotiation and if you get upset during
the negotiations which you likely will
because these are difficult topics how
to divide up responsibilities in the
house and people get mad because they
feel they've been taken advantage of or
aren't being listened to one of the
rules was well you can leave the
discussion but only until you calm down
and then you have to come back because
these things have to be
pushed through they have to be
negotiated through because the
alternative is well important things
don't get done or people do them
resentfully because they're sort of
forced by their own orderliness or their
own conscientiousness or or
but we know by force psychological or
otherwise on the part of other people
these things have to be negotiated
through you can tell if you've got the
balance between making peace and
speaking the truth right if the
conversation continues and it can be
emotional and will be and can be
difficult because important things have
to be dealt with but as long as
the people are still in the conversation
and communicating then you then you've
got the balance right you know and you
might have to take a break
maybe you have to hold off till the next
day
maybe sometimes when you're negotiating
something that's difficult you have to
offer that other person the opportunity
to sleep on their decision too which I
think is often a very good idea if you
have to make an important decision in
your life it's very useful to tell the
person that you're negotiating with it
look I'm interested in this and it seems
good but I'm not going to agree until I
sleep on it gives you
well lots of things happen when you
sleep you organize your brain when you
sleep at least to the degree that you
can organize it and you can often be
more solid or more doubtful about a
decision if you sleep on it you need a
meaning to sustain you through the
vicissitudes of life okay well try to
debate that it's like is life painful
yes is it anxiety provoking yes is it
uncertain yes is it painful Beyond
bearing sometimes yes it's difficult
everyone agrees about that now they
might disagree about how difficult but
that doesn't matter that the Central
Point holds okay
what if you think that's all pointless
well that doesn't seem very helpful okay
so you need a sustaining meaning well
where do you find that
well
you generally find it in responsibility
to yourself and other people something
that I learned for example from Jean
Piaget he called that an equilibrated
state in equilibrated state is like a
game that everyone wants to play and so
if you set your household up properly
then it's a game that everybody is
participating in voluntarily and that's
going to be predicated on the desire for
peace and the willingness to speak truth
and the ability to take responsibility
so that has to be part of your higher
order moral aim and then when you're
having a difficult discussion with
someone
the discussion is going to be affected
by that higher order moral aim it's not
going to be contaminated to the same
degree by your desire to inflict pain
and attain Victory and you know crush
your opponent and punish them for their
previous sins and
indicate your disappointment things
they've done over the years and all of
that it's hard to say what the soul
means metaphysically because you know
say beyond the cons beyond the confines
of a single human being
we do have this sense that the soil can
expand itself into something that's
greater than well greater than it has be
it has this capacity for growth and we
do have the sense that the soil can
expand itself to the point where it it's
enlightened for lack of a better word
that it's working
as efficiently as possible to transform
everything that's
unnecessarily painful and malevolent
about the world into what's positive and
good and and and that it does that as a
consequence of confronting the world
with courage and truth and I I think
that's right and I do think that that
means that the soul participates in
something internal which is the attempt
of being itself to transform what's
unnecessarily painful and malevolent
into what's good and that human beings
actually do participate in that and that
that's part of the reason that our
ancient tradition insists that we're
made in the image of God
and I think that it's a mistake to
underestimate the importance of that
because I don't think that you can live
life a life of sufficient profundity to
protect yourself from being corrupted by
suffering malevolence without adopting a
responsibility that's commensurate with
that set of ideas I think that you
either
Orient yourself upward you know to the
star above the Horizon and try
desperately to improve the structure of
being
or you work at counter purposes to it
and make things worse I don't think
there's a middle ground
in fact to the degree there is a middle
ground it tilts towards the negative
because people who try to occupy the
middle ground
um
try to
generally try to accrue the benefit
let's say without adopting any of the
risk and that's not
acceptable not helpful
so
that's a soul to me if you're having a
discussion with someone
and they're talking about things that
don't have those characteristics right
that they haven't made personal then the
conversation is almost never interesting
it's because the person is it's just a
they're just they really are an empty
shell through which
ideologue ideology cliches and slogans
are pouring there's nothing about that
that's compelling because you don't see
the grappling you don't see that the
other person has grappled with the ideas
and come to their own unique conclusions
and it really is in that mingling of the
abstract and the particular that
compelling wisdom is to be found
and so that's that's
and then concretely speaking well
there's ways of earning your knowledge
and part of that is reformulating it in
your own words that's thinking it
through right and discussing it until
you have it at hand you can talk about
it and you can generalize from it
because you truly understand it but a
huge part of that is also putting it
into practice and deriving your own
conclusions as a consequence and some of
that can be done with debate it's like
here's an idea I came across and
here's the idea and here's what I think
it means and this is how I think it
would change things if I put it into
practice this is how I understand this
idea and what do you think of that like
that's a good debate or discussion you
know because then the other person can
say well I don't really agree with what
you formulated that or I don't agree
with your conclusions and hopefully it's
a real discussion and not just one
upmanship you know because that's a
pretty dull game when you're trying to
lead people forward out of the darkness
let's say out of anxiety and depression
and despair and and resentment
bitterness and anger and all of those
things catastrophic
interactions with their family is that
you get them to stop avoiding
confronting the terrible things that are
in front of them right so basically what
you do instead of saying to them you
know those terrible things that are
happening just ignore those and and find
some peace right get your mind away from
it that isn't what you say you say turn
around and look at them even more than
you've been looking at them it's a very
paradoxical advice but of all the things
that have been proven to Aid people's
recovery and movement towards mental
health that's like at the top of the
list voluntary confrontation with what
you are afraid of or or what you despise
even for that matter and so Jung had an
axiom that he derived from The Alchemist
which was interquilinus invenator which
meant roughly meant that which you most
need will be found where you least want
to look which is fat man yeah well
that's it that was also his explanation
for why people weren't enlightened
because you think well the California
approached Enlightenment to speak you
know kind of satirically is follow your
bliss it's like well that's easy if that
was the case everyone would be
enlightened but the union approaches no
no no you do what's meaningful and pay
attention follow the truth and it will
take you to the worst place you can
imagine and then maybe there's some
chance for enlightenment soul is also
the center of the world which is a
frightening proposition and not one
that's easily comprehensible
archipelago is particularly enlightening
in this regard
um
because he insisted that it was a pre
conception of our judeo-christian
heritage that each person was the center
of the cosmos and you can think of that
as
a center of Consciousness right a center
from which being itself is not only
reflected but also generated and it was
Soulja Nixon's
belief and dostoevskies as well and I
think Jung would have been in accordance
with this and Nietzsche as well
for that matter that
in some manner that we don't fathom
because we don't understand the
structure of the world very well the
outcome of
the world is dependent on our choices
and and equally on all of our choices
and it I don't understand I know that's
I know that to be true or feel that to
be true
it's it's part of the doctrine that each
person is of intrinsic and equal worth
the part of that Doctrine is that each
person is has intrinsic and equal
responsibility and that we're each
capable of generating a fair bit of hell
around us and for other people but also
capable of generating a tremendous
amount of good and that the fate of the
world as it careens through
eternity is actually a consequence of
the ethical decisions of each of us it's
a terrifying idea it's no wonder people
flee from it into Hedonism let's say and
and ideology because it's very
frightening possibility that the choices
that you make day to day
or fail to make
have this profound and Lasting effect on
the structure of reality but I don't
really see any way out of that
conclusion compare yourself to who you
were yesterday
not to who someone else is today and the
reason I wrote that was because I had
this client 10 I'm a clinical
psychologist and I spent 20 hours a week
for 25 years listening to people
listening to people tell me about their
lives you know and and those people were
people who were just barely hanging on
to the bottom of the world up to people
who were so successful you can hardly
believe it like the entire gamut of
people and and that's been absolutely
fascinating it's like it's like being a
clinical psychologist if you really
listen is like being immersed in a
Dostoevsky novel all the time you know
because it's amazing what people will
tell you if you listen to them they are
people are so interesting if you
actually listen to them because they're
so peculiar like they're like penguins
or rhinoceroses and ostriches they're
unlikely creatures and anyways
um with regards to
um
to uh
comparing yourself to who you were
yesterday and not just who someone else
is today
um this old client of mine he was about
85 when he came to see me and he was a
financier and a kind of a mathematical
genius he made these little pendants out
of a a mathematical symbol for the most
beautiful mathematical equation that was
ever written that he made them out of
gold and he would hand those out and and
he he had studied psychology as a young
man and he introduced me to this concept
that I didn't know about called the
Pareto distribution which see I'd been
taught as a psychologist that most human
characteristics
were normally distributed right so most
people were average and some people were
extreme that's a pre or our normal
distribution intelligence is like that
and height there's more people of
average height than than very tall or
very short and and weight is like that
and lots of things are normally
distributed and psychologists tend to
assume that everything is but it isn't
creative products are distributed in a
Pareto distribution and that's a whole
different thing and it's really
important to know this it's another
fundamental fact the knowledge of which
can sort of transform the way you
conceptualize let's say the political
landscape so here here's an example of
the Pareto distribution of you know
there's a rule of thumb that if you run
a company that 20 of your employees do
80 of the work or the 20 of your
customers are responsible for 80 of your
sales or the 20 of them are responsible
for 80 of the customer service calls
same thing but that's not exactly the
rule the rule is worse than that the
rule is
in a given domain the square root of the
number of people operating in that
domain do half the productive work
so you think well you have 10 employees
three of them do half the work it's like
yeah okay what if you have 100 employees
then 10 of them do half the work what if
you have a thousand employees well then
it's 30 and if it's ten thousand
employees then it's a hundred and this
actually turns out to be a rather iron
Cloud rule it it applies across very
very many situations it applies for
example to the mass of stars and the
size of cities so you can see how
Universal it is as a law and it's it's
something like those that have more get
more and those that have less get less
that's the Matthew principle right to
those who have everything more will be
given from those who have nothing
everything will be taken away and the
economists sometimes call that the
Matthew principle and so what what that
lays out is a world that's Rife with
inequality so you know you you hear this
idea that I think it's the 85 richest
people in the world have more money than
the bottom two billion that's a Pareto
distribution phenomena and you might say
to hell with capitalism for producing
that it's like sorry you got your
diagnosis wrong it's a natural law it's
no matter what Society you study you get
a Pareto distribution of wealth you get
a predo distribution of number of
Records recorded you get a predo
distribution of number of Songs written
or goals scored like any creative
product has that characteristic and it's
partly because as you start to become
successful let's say people offer you
more and more opportunities and as you
start to fail people move away from you
and you plummet and so
okay so that's rough so what it is what
it means is that there is always a
landscape of inequality and I'm not
saying that we shouldn't do anything
about it although I am saying that we
don't know what to do about it that's
the thing you know because you can
modify the Pareto distribution of wealth
let's say but if you but we don't know
how to do it without maybe disrupting
the system so completely that it
collapses which is what happened in the
Soviet Union for example and in maoist
China they were trying at least in
principle to adjust inequality
but the Cure was far worse than the
disease and the the truth of the matter
is we actually don't know technically
how much inequality there has to be to
generate wealth we can guess and you
could say well there should be less and
you might say well there should be more
if you're left-wing you'd say less and
if they're if you're right wing you'd
say well we'll just let the inequality
flourish but we do know that it's
inevitable and we we also know that we
don't know how to regulate it so there
is inequality what that means is there's
always going to be people around that
are better at something than you are and
the and that's a that's a problem
because you can get jealous and you can
get bitter and you can get resentful and
worse you can get hopeless you know
because you look like look I have this
this friend of mine he told me something
so funny
um he was he was decrying his his lack
of success in the world and he compared
himself to his roommate and uh he said
you know his roommate his college
roommate was doing much better than he
was and his bloody roommate was Elon
Musk it's like really like it's like oh
you're not doing as well as Elon Musk
well I mean you can see it would take it
rather personally because they were
roommates and everything it wasn't like
he was doing badly like he wasn't doing
pretty damn well it's like I'm not as
good as Elon Musk it's like yeah well
you and like seven billion other people
you know but yeah but I thought it was
instructive because well because you
have to be careful who you compare
yourself to now you can't just not
compare yourself to others to successful
people right because then you don't have
anything to aim at one of the
things I've thought about a fair bit is
the meaning of The Sermon on the Mount
And as far as I can tell it's it's a
it's basically a two-part it's two-part
wisdom the first is that you should aim
at the highest good that you can imagine
and that would be a good that includes
everyone right so if I wanted what was
good for you say if I genuinely wanted
it I wanted in a way that was good for
you now and good in the long run and
good for you and your family and your
community and maybe good for me too you
know you could conceive of that as the
desire and I think that's a good
definition of Love is that you actually
want the best you want the best possible
outcome and in the gospels of course
that's extended even to your enemies yes
right is that okay if we're gonna have
things good let's have it good enough
for even the people that set themselves
up against me because if the world was
running properly things would be good
for them too and that would be better
and it seems to me that that's a very
good way of looking at things it's a
difficult way of looking at things and
then the second part of The Sermon on
the Mount is something like
having established that as your aim
which is no easy thing by the way right
because you have to be pretty
clear-headed and single-minded to
actually want that to be your aim then
you can concentrate on the day and you
can try telling the truth and you can
Ally so there's truth and love that are
Allied together truth love and attention
it's something like that that are all
Allied together
um with regards to transgressing against
the vulnerable if you're plagued by
boats of depression and anxiety that
does destabilize your identity so
um it's almost by definition but having
said that look this is when habit and
plan
and strategy are so useful so in the
periods of depression that I've had what
sustain some of them were long and and
and and certainly the most unpleasant
experiences of My Life
um you this is when you need a
philosophy let's say that's allied with
your vision and your strategy to sustain
you because what would what would happen
to me is that
I know I have these a vision and I
suppose the vision is of a world that's
better in in that's less likely to
descend into ideological catastrophe and
where people are more responsible and
more awake
and more educated and and and healthier
all of that a vision of a better world
you know a world that's less hellish at
least but also a better world and some
sense of what role I might play in that
and and so that's very motivating like
it's a profound goal to to try to make
things better and you can do that
locally you can do that for yourself you
can do that for your family you can do
that for the broader community and all
of that's worth it man it's worth making
some sacrifices for it we're suffering
for to some degree and then you
decompose that into the day-to-day and
week to week strategies and actions that
you're undertaking the plans and and and
and the activities that you're putting
forward to make that dream a reality to
realize it and then when the depression
and anxiety come along you think
part of it with depression it's like
it's just bloody endurance it's like
you get up and you work through the next
hour you try to stay on track you try to
implement your strategic plans to the
best of your ability and you hope and
you pray that you'll get through it
you know you'll get through it and that
the darkness will recede and you you you
you stay on track you eat even though
you're not hungry you get up even though
you want to stay in bed you interact
with people even though you'd rather be
alone and it's it's it's it's the
benefit of disciplined habits
can can sustain you it's like the boat
you're rowing in through a terrible
storm leaks and all and maybe you'll be
overwhelmed but you have the boat and
you can roll forward and that's what
you've got and so endurance is a huge
part of it and then I would say with its
anxiety it's the same thing it's like or
very much the same as you're terrified
and and uncertain but you move ahead to
the best of your ability and again you
operate at least to some degree on Hope
and if you haven't got hope then you've
got blind bloody endurance and that's
all motivated by some sense that you're
working towards something that's
worthwhile working to work you know and
and that is well that's your own
long-term well-being to treat yourself
properly it's the stability and
productivity and Harmony and health of
your family that's a huge deal and then
it's whatever benefit you can be to the
community
and if you have to limp along and drag
yourself forward in order to maintain
that pathway then so be it because
it's better than the alternative higher
on the basis of competence
using objective tests and let the cards
fall where they're going to and don't be
afraid to tell people that that's what
you're doing watch your HR department
carefully and make sure that they're not
pushing
diversity inclusivity and Equity
initiatives that they're not requiring
people to take implicit Association
tests that hypothetically reveal their
unconscious bias that they're not doing
seminars on systemic racism and
Prejudice and then they're not making
the assumption that
unequal outcomes let's say in terms of
hiring in the stem fields or in terms of
employment in the stem fields which by
the way are radically overestimated if
you unless you gerrymander what
constitutes the definition of a stem
discipline you just have to you have to
not participate in any of that and you
have to make it known to your peers
which who would be other Silicon Valley
Founders I would presume that you're not
doing any of that you need an ideal
because you have nothing to aim at but
an ideal is a judge and you always fall
short of the ideal so how the hell can
you have the benefits of having an ideal
without having the crushing blow that
goes along with having the judge that
always regards you as insufficient so I
was trying to work that out in the
chapter and this is something I've had
to work out a lot as a clinical
psychologist it's like well
let's say you need a goal but we don't
want to let your distance from the goal
Crush you so you got to set up a goal
and then you got to make the goal break
the goal down into parts so that you can
move towards it you have a fairly High
likelihood of doing it so that's a bit
of practical I wouldn't say advice it's
it's because it's better than advice
it's it's some practical knowledge about
how to go about achieving an aim set a
high aim but differentiate it down so
you know what the next step is and then
make the next step difficult enough so
you have to push yourself past where you
are but but also provide yourself with a
reasonable probability of success it's
also what you do with children right you
you want to push them because they need
to grow up and be more than they are
right but you don't want to crush them
with constant failure so what you do is
aim high and make the goal approx
difficult but proximal I think that the
best approach to ameliorating
inequalities to strengthen the
individual I mean that's and that's what
I've concentrated on doing like we have
this program this self-authoring suite
and there's a component of that that
helps people write an autobiography and
another component that helps them write
an analysis of their personality and
another component that helps them write
out a plan for the future and we've used
that we've studied the effect of having
people write out a detailed plan for
their future and it's a proper plan it's
like okay look you you get to have what
you want three to five years down the
road you get to have the friends you
want you get to have the family you want
you get to have the career you want the
education you get you get to take care
of yourself properly you get to
withstand
The Temptations of drug and alcohol
abuse and other sorts of impulsive
Pleasures you get to make productive and
meaningful use of your time okay what
does that look like for you write it out
what does it look like just you need a
vision and then you need another vision
of how terrible things could be if you
let all your bad habits get the upper
hand and we've had people do that in an
experimental situation and mostly they
were college students and the
consequences of that there were two
consequences one was General which was
that University students were about 30
percent more likely to stay in
University and got grades there were
about 25 percent better which is a
walloping effect but even more
interestingly and this is the coolest
thing I think that we ever discovered as
in our in our psychological research
we did this research in Holland at the
um
at the Erasmus University in Rotterdam
at the Rotterdam School of Management
and we ran business students through the
future authoring program for multiple
years so several thousands of them and
we stratified them by gender and
ethnicity pretty a pretty rough cut men
and women and then
Dutch Nationals and non-western ethnic
minorities okay and so the the
performance was like this the Dutch
women were at the top
then the Dutch man
then the then the non-western ethnic
minority women then the non-western
ethnic minority men and they were behind
the Dutch women by by by they they
showed about an 80 decrement in
performance really quite catastrophic
two years after they did the future
authoring program they were ahead of the
Dutch women
it just blew us away because it was and
it was a perfect indication of the fact
that you can use a psychological
intervention to ameliorate what looks
like a sociological problem I've had
clients many clients in their 30s who
are trying to this is more true with
women I would say a lot of women who
were very high achieving who established
their career goals at 30 and then
want to differentiator differentiate out
their life they want to have a husband
they want to have a family they're
trying to figure out how to do that and
one of the things I've noticed that
around 30
you really have to stop comparing
yourself in some ways to other people
and the reason for that is that the
particularities of your life are so
idiosyncratic that there isn't anyone
really all that much like you you know
because the details of your life happen
to matter and so maybe you compare
yourself to some rock star or something
like that and you know the person's rich
and famous and glamorous and all that
but you know they're alcoholic and they
use too much cocaine and they've had
three divorces and it's like how the
hell do you
make sense out of that is that someone
that you should judge yourself harshly
against or not the answer is you don't
know because you don't know all the
details of their lives and who do you
know that you can compare yourself to
that's easy you yesterday
so here's a good goal it's something
like well aim high and I really mean
that it's like and we'll talk about that
a little bit too aim high but use as
your control yourself it's like so your
goal is to make today some tiny
increment better than yesterday and you
can use better you can Define better
yourself this doesn't have to be some
imposition of external morality you know
you know where you're weak and
insufficient where you could improve you
think okay well this is what I'm like
yesterday if I did this little thing
things would be just an increment better
and well that's a great thing because
you get the ball rolling and incremental
Improvement is Unstoppable you can
actually implement it and it starts to
generate Pareto distribution like
consequences it starts to compound and
I've seen that happen in people's lives
over and on people write me all the time
and tell me that they're doing that but
I've seen that happen in people's lives
continually they make a goal a goal that
the goal should be
how could I conceive of my life so that
if I had that life it would clearly be
worth living so I wouldn't have to be
bitter resentful deceitful arrogant and
vengeful you act out the things that you
would do when you're normal even when
you're depressed you know you don't want
to see people well it doesn't matter you
go see them because it's better than not
seeing them you know and you find when
you do see them that it's better it'll
go better than you think but you can't
isolate yourself and you're anxious and
so you want to avoid you don't want to
go out you'd rather stay home and sit in
the chair and just sit there and like in
a frozen positions like you can't do
that you have to go out and go grocery
shopping and go out and have coffee and
all of those things it doesn't matter
whether you enjoy them it matters that
you do them because that's what you do
that's what you do in order to maintain
your health don't recommend any changes
that you wouldn't suffer for if they
failed
how's that
and that's the problem with large-scale
political action it's like well here's
how we should change things it's like
well they changed them it's well it
fails it doesn't bother me it doesn't
hurt me I'm not involved in it it's like
you should be careful when you try to
change things to make sure you suffer
for your own stupidity of course head
down endurance and that'll get you
through bad times that endurance it's
it's it's such an under
represented virtue that ability to
trudge forward under a
trudge forward unhappily under uh
unfairly burdensome load is a testament
to character if you can and then it's
something that should be
encouraged and
valued
so you know and I'm not making the claim
that people who are depressed who can't
get out of bed lack endurance some do
and some don't because depression comes
in very varied uh degrees of intensity
and and you can be laid out completely
by depression
so I'm not trying to make some arbitrary
judgment about who's got endurance and
who hasn't you can't do that from the
outside but I can say that endurance is
one of the tools you have to deal with
chronic discomfort and pain
you know and even if you have chronic
pain it's interesting because it's very
much allied with depression by the way
all of the research on chronic pain back
pain for example indicates in chronic
pain of All Sorts is that
the more you allow your pain to render
you inactive the worst the outcome
including exacerbation of the pain and
depression is a pain disorder and so
that's very much worth thinking about
too it's like move forward move forward
move forward
you know and if you need to talk to
somebody about what your plan is for the
day or the hour or the week then do that
as well and perhaps you also have to
help get the people around you to help a
bit I need a little bit of help getting
up in the morning I need to have
breakfast made for me so that all I do
when I get up in my in my terrible state
of fog and confusion and terrible
anxiety and depression is I have a
shower because that's what happens first
and then the next thing is I eat and
then that's better you're at least
you're out of bed and moving and that's
that's a start you know so
and then you endure and Hope
and that's how it is and you do the same
thing when someone in your family is
sick or when you're facing a death all
of that it's like one bloody foot in
front of the other up the hill you can
ask yourself that question what would
make this worthwhile I quote Nietzsche I
think in that chapter he said he who has
a why can bear almost any how that's a
lovely line man I mean it's a lovely
line and it's really worth thinking
about so you think well how do I manage
all this misery and suffering and
futility it's like well I need to figure
out what I would have to do in order to
make that clearly worthwhile and so then
you have your goal and then you think
well I need to move towards that
incrementally because I'm kind of
useless and can only do so much and
maybe not even that and but all I have
to do is be a little bit better than my
my miserable self yesterday
and that'll Propel you forward very
rapidly and and you can succeed at it
which is also really lovely because why
not set yourself up for Success you know
because otherwise you droop around like
a number 10 Lobster and you know that's
just not good you get all Pinchy when
that happens and it's not a good thing
we discovered that we could let go of
something we value in the present and we
would gain something we value even more
in the future we acted that out
dramatically in all sorts of strange
ways over thousands and thousands of
years before it was formalizable
psychologically but it's a massive
Discovery I can forego gratification in
a particular way
and benefit in the future so I can share
the proceeds of my hunt
and I store up future food in the form
of reputation
and the favors I've owed I'm old now by
other people
it's a massive Discovery one of the
things I've learned
if you're if you have a dispute with
someone
and
it needs to be settled and maybe they
need to change more than you and that's
not always the case because sometimes
the settling requires change on your
part but let's say that they have to be
defeated in some sense
in comparison to you you don't want to
defeat them any more than necessary you
know it's like you don't knock your
opponent to the ground and then jump up
and down on them three or four times in
in Triumph you know you you
pin them and then and then let them up
minimal necessary Force
because any more than that just produces
a counter-reaction
and so
and I guess the other thing is too is my
motivation when I'm engaged let's say in
these discussions is that I'm not trying
to win the argument
I'm not trying to win
I'm trying to say what I think as
clearly as I can and there is
there might be an element
there might be one of the consequences
of that might be
what appears to be a victory but
the right Victory is the victory for
your ability to articulate what you
believe
and that's what I'm trying to do and so
that's another reason
to stay composed it's like well okay
this person is just throwing a curveball
at me it's like all right so
well
I could be thinking well I don't want to
be undermined by that and I don't want
to make a fool of myself and I don't
want to be put on the spot and of course
all those things are true but mostly
what I'm thinking about is okay well now
I've got that question
I want to answer as truthfully as I
possibly can
what do I think about what was just said
and I'm not calculating the outcome
I'm assuming this is a Mark of Faith
right this is the faith that that that
that people have talked about
being
something that
has to be manifested necessarily we've
been talking about this since the dawn
of time what's the faith the faith is
that if you say what you believe to be
true then whatever happens is the best
thing that could have happened
and I believe that so that's and I
really believe it
partly because I believe that if you're
deceitful which is the opposite of that
or manipulative or malicious or
malevolent
but maybe primarily manipulative
then what you're acting out is your
belief that deceit will
bring Victory and I just don't believe
that at all I I just I think it's a
Preposterous claim
and so if the seek won't bring Victory
then truth is what brings Victory if
there is such a thing as truth and
there's certainly such a thing as deceit
so there must be such a thing as truth
and so
and some of it's just curiosity too it's
like well I'm going to say what I think
and see what happens that's an adventure
you know that's the adventure of your
life really and you don't want to miss
that because
that's what you've got in your life is
for it to be an adventure it's not an
easy Road you know it's a stormy sea and
what you have is the adventure of
contending with God and the waves that's
what you have
and
the way you do that is with truth
and
then that sort of takes you out of that
immediacy of the conflict whoever it is
that the conflict with whoever it is
that you're talking to
you're trying to Ally yourself with
something that's
deeper and more profound
and more lasting do what is Meaningful
not what is expedient and to to view the
world as a place of resources that can
be delivered to you it's in some sense
to be expedient is to take the short
term it's to take the approach of
short-term gratification something like
that yes self-centered it's
materialistic too well it is
materialistic but it's also it's also
it's not optimal and it's not wise and
the reason for that is is that it
actually turns out like if we're gonna
have If We Had A continuing relationship
I would want to try to do a little bit
more for you than you do for me and I
could do that even purely selfishly say
because if I did a little bit more for
you than you did for me you would want
to keep interacting with me and I'll
tell you man if you want to have a good
relationship with someone that's one
thing you don't do you open your bloody
eyes and if they do something that you
would like them to do again then you
tell them how much you appreciated the
fact that that happened and you hope
that it replicates you know you see
that that's if there's one thing you can
take away from tonight's lecture that's
that's an extraordinarily useful thing
to know watch and when people do
something that they should do more of
say look I saw that you did this
specific thing I saw that it took some
effort here's what it meant here's
here's how I observed it's like keep
that up and man if you love someone you
do that to them that's that's
encouragement that's such a great thing
the positive emotion that we find
sustaining is experienced in
relationship to an unachieved goal
it's hope that drives us forward we want
something and if we see ourselves moving
towards that
then we're we're in the grip of the
positive emotion that we find sustaining
it isn't the attainment attainment is
satiating attainment shuts down the
system that has been striving for that
particular object of attainment if
you're hungry and you eat you stop being
hungry now that's good because the
hunger is gone but that whole frame
disappears
you can no longer strive within that
frame
and you need a new frame to strive
towards
and so technically and this is well
established as far as I'm concerned we
even know the drugs that people abuse
cocaine let's say amphetamines the ones
that are potent sources of positive
emotion activate the system that
regulates our emotional response to
evidence that we're moving towards a
desired goal
so cocaine for example
is an exhilarating drug it makes you
feel that things are worthwhile because
it hijacks the system that does make
indicate that things are worthwhile
so this is deeply this this striving
aspect is deeply rooted in in our in our
biology
for obvious reasons a lot of people
don't read because they're afraid of
books
the books aren't their friend so you
might want to get a few books and kind
of make them your friend
um you can start with
simpler books you know like fiction
there's lots of good fiction writing for
adolescents and children
it's pretty straightforward you can
start there
if you're interested in philosophy
there's lots of
simple guides like the idiot's guide to
um different topics or a beginner's
guide I read those things all the time
when I'm first investigating a new topic
you know I start with the introductory
material
and I make time for reading like what
and it was that was encouraged in my
family like I always read before I went
to sleep I read
and I I still do that
um somewhat less so because I've become
so distracted by social media
but uh
you set aside a bit of time every day to
read and for me it was always just
before I went to bed I'd go to bed turn
on the light and read for oh when I was
a kid for hours but
and if you do something every day you do
a lot of it and so I would say well if
you want to read if you want to make
yourself educated just put aside
20 minutes a day to read or 10 you know
some small amount of time that you could
actually steal not two hours because
good luck man it's very unlikely you'll
manage that but 20 minutes a day you
know that's
two hours a week that's 700 hours a year
you know that's
even if you're a slow reader that's a
good number of books
and so you make it a habitual part of
your life and you decide that it's going
to be something that you value you
investigate carefully what resistances
you might have to that idea because you
might think well that's uh
pseudo-intellectual or there's something
more productive I could be doing or I'm
intimidated by books or I hate books
because I wasn't good at reading when I
was a kid and was humiliated because of
it or you know you've got something
against intellectuals or
God there might all sorts of resistances
to picking up a book then you could
listen to audiobooks that's a good way
around that by hooker by crook man
so
you value it you make it a regular part
of your life you practice doing it and
and you you need a higher goal too it's
like well why should you read well it's
so that you're more informed and you can
think better why should you be more
informed and think better because you
won't walk blindly into so many pits
you know you'll be able to negotiate
better in your life because you'll be
more
informed and more verbally fluent and
you'll have a better sense of how the
world works and be able to hold your own
in conversations and that'll make you
more confident those are all
unbelievably good reasons to be highly
literate is is an incredibly massive
massive advantage practical Advantage
you know and it shouldn't be
underestimated I already knew that I was
a pretty decent Monster by the time I
had kids and I thought well my kid my
kid's little you know like a baby or
two-year-olds like I'm a horrible
monster and so that this is an uneven
power problem here I better not let that
child do anything that really makes me
angry you know now you hear now and then
you hear about something horrible that
happens I when I was in Boston years ago
I read about a woman who plunged her
two-year-old daughter's arms into
boiling water you think well how in the
world can that happen it's like well you
know
she's probably hungover
she probably just lost her job
she's probably desperate in six
different ways she probably didn't have
any decent disciplinary disciplinary
strategies for children she probably
didn't have anyone helping her she was
bitter and resentful and angry and the
child misbehaved at exactly the wrong
moment and like you're going to be
around your children a lot and so you
might want to have it so that they don't
misbehave at exactly the wrong moment
because all all hell can break loose if
they can and I didn't want that to
happen so and I knew that it was easy
for people to hate their children even
though they mouth the words that they
love them all the time I saw very little
evidence of that many situations and so
one of the things you know you have a
natural affinity for children and even
more maybe a more powerful natural
affinity for your own children so that's
a good start but you don't want to set
them up as an enemy against you you
don't want to allow them to engage in
the kind of hierarchical challenge that
makes you irritable and resentful that's
not a good idea and if the things they
do make you dislike them the probability
that they will make other people people
just like them is extraordinarily high
and so you can consult your own
irritability and you can say look kid I
used to tell my kids this you know when
they were three or four I'd say look I'm
not in a very good mood and I'm likely
to be unreasonable so it'd be best if
you'd go in your room and play for a
while it's like I like you man you're a
great kid but like get the hell out of
here for a while you know and they were
fine with that we'd trained them already
at that point to be able to go play by
themselves in the room you know which is
something a kid should be able to do
anyways but but you need to know what
sort of monster you are if you're going
to be a good parent and if you think oh
I'm not a monster it's like oh yes you
are you're just an unbelievably
unconscious monster and that's actually
the worst kind so and then the other
thing about that chapter is there's an
idea in it and and it's an idea that I
think is well supported by the relevant
literature which is that your
fundamental job as a parent especially
of a child from zero to four is to make
that child eminently desirable socially
so what you're you're a successful
parent if when your child is four all
sorts of other children want to play
with him or her that's really the that's
like if you want one marker of whether
or not you've been successful that's it
now some children are a lot harder to
get along with than others and some
children have a harder time playing and
so I'm not saying that every parent who
has a child that isn't popular at four
is is at fault for that I'm not saying
that I'm saying the reverse which is you
can be sure that you've been successful
if your child is not popular exactly but
desirable as a playmate and so then you
think well what have you done for your
child well you've opened up the entire
world of children to them so because
they know how to play which is a very
deep knowledge and and it starts to
become inculcated probably at the breast
and certainly in the course of rough and
tumble play at about two years of age
it's a deep embodied knowledge they know
how to play like a good well-trained dog
knows how to play you know he meets a
new dog and you go like this and the dog
goes like this you think oh that dog I
can go like this and it won't bite me
right it knows how to play and a kid
who's awake and alert is just like that
like a well-socialized kit if you know
anything about kids is you can take a
four-year-old and make a little play
gesture at them and they'll smile right
away and start playing just right now
and that's what you want for your kids
and then everywhere they go other kids
like them and we'll include them in
their Play and play is the way the
children develop and so if other
children include them in their play then
the children develop and the poor kids
that don't get befriended at the age of
four with the literature on this is
Crystal Clear if your child is an
outcast at the age of four the
probability that anything can be done
about that is almost zero no matter what
you do and I hate to be so blunt about
that but I know the literature and
that's what the literature suggests
there's a part of the brain called the
hypothalamus and it's very very very old
we share it with virtually every animal
that has a nervous system it's it's sits
above the spinal cord it's extremely old
evolutionarily speaking and half of it
governs fundamental motivation so
governs hunger for example so if you're
hungry
you posit the existence of something
that will satiate your appetite a peanut
butter sandwich and then you're happy
when you're moving towards the kitchen
and then maybe you get thirsty and the
hypothalamus does that and then maybe
you need to use the washroom and maybe
you're too hot and that the hypothalamus
pops up these little motivational frames
and then emotions modulate your movement
towards the goal that's established by
these fundamental motivations but that's
only half the hypothalamus the other
half is the origin of the dopaminergic
system that mediates exploratory
striving and positive emotion and so the
way our brains are set up way below what
way below the neocortex way way older
than that the default position is if
you're satiated in all the important
dimensions
then you're curious and explore well why
well because you might find new
resources that could be used to
to to uh satiate those fundamental
motivations in the future so that heroic
drive into the unknown is unbelievably
archaic
and then it's regulated by fear and pain
you know so you go into the unknown well
you don't want to die so if you get
damaged you experience pain and you want
to avoid pain so you experience anxiety
these are very fundamental systems and
they are reflected in our narratives
that's essentially as far as I can tell
why
the dragon horde's treasure everywhere
the dragon is an amalgam of predatory
stimuli and Fire
which is a destructive force but also
very useful so dragon is something like
predatory destructive entity you might
say well is that real it's like well
yeah but it's a meta-category it's like
there are lions and Raptors and
um lizards let's say uh 60 million years
ago when we were still in trees
the idea that there's a meta Predator is
a great idea a meta Predator is what all
predators share in common
that's a dragon well what should you do
with a dragon
well avoid it that's one answer another
answer is burn it out of its layer so
that it doesn't have baby dragons the
and the uh an even more sophisticated
answer is well
confront it
you can feed your family with the body
of a dragon
it's treasure there's a higher order
moral principle that needs to be brought
into the situation and you sort of
described that right at the beginning of
the question because you said well what
partly what you do when you move from an
addicted state from a psychological
perspective is move from a Viewpoint of
the gratification of immediate desire
and and maybe the accumulation of things
as a marker of success to the notion
that no you actually have a higher
purpose and that higher purpose might
involve being of service that could be
of service to yourself which means you
wouldn't be addicted anymore because
that's not a good way of being of
service to yourself but of service to
yourself and the broader Community
however you might Define that that's a
higher order purpose and it can
integrate your motivations at at a level
that doesn't leave you at the whim of
impulse that's the purpose of a higher
order motivation you do what you can to
make the things around you better you
better your family better and then
whatever you can manage in your
community
you know um if you're interested in drug
addicted in the mentally ill no there
are volunteer you could volunteer
you could talk to those people and
listen because then you'd find out what
the hell their problems are and then
you'd have some sense about how they
might be helped you know but that's a
hard thing there's no
helping from above
drug addiction and it's combination with
mental illness unbelievably complicated
problems there's no Simple Solutions
so and it isn't even necessarily obvious
that the people that you see who are
homeless and drug addicted and mentally
ill don't want to be helped is that
sometimes they have problems that are so
absolutely overwhelming that they can't
be helped
in any real sense you know like if
they're
unmedicated schizophrenic for example
with a drug problem it's God it's just
it's just a nightmarish it's a nightmare
of insane complexity because
schizophrenia is very very difficult to
deal with even
even
with medication because the
medication that helps people who are
schizophrenic also tends to depress
their positive emotion and decrease
their motivation you know so the
medications are generally helpful and
the proper treatment guidelines if your
schizophrenic generally are stay with
your medication
because
despite the negative consequences of the
medication which aren't trivial
the consequences of not taking it are
worse and that's a real Hobson's choice
right it's a bit of Hell in both
directions
but if you really want to know I would
say
go have some
contact with those people
and listen to them
and learn what the problems are maybe
you could start seeing what might be
helpful it's a really complicated
problem
and it's different than the problem of
helping people who don't want to be
helped because you have to figure out
who it is that doesn't want to be helped
first and you don't want to assume that
just because someone's homeless that
they don't want to be helped
I mean
that doesn't mean that it's easy to
figure out how to help them it's not
easy it's helping people is a very
difficult business and it's a very
dangerous business too because you get
tangled up in ways that you wouldn't
expect and that can be
an occupational hazard let's put it that
way if you don't allow your children to
engage in dislikable Behavior then
adults will like them because adults
actually like kids you know one of the
things I loved about having little kids
in Montreal I lived in a poor area in
Montreal there's a lot of rough guys
around there and we used to roll our
daughter around in the stroller these
rough guys you know like
God only knows what they were up to
they're rough looking guys you know we'd
roll our daughter by them and they'd
they'd like smile and they'd crouched
down and make little goo faces and you
know they were
you I tell you one of the great things
about having little kids is they bring
out the best in other people you see a
whole side of humanity even among the
darker parts of humanity you see a whole
side of them that you wouldn't normally
see and it's lovely and the thing is if
you're good to your kid in the real way
you can help them maintain that
tremendous attractiveness that they have
as young children and to respond to
adults properly like a puppy that wags
its tail instead of growls and you know
goes for your ankle and then wherever
they go adults welcome them and teach
them things and Pat them on the head and
smile at them genuinely instead of
saying oh my God here comes that couple
with that goddamn brat again you know
which is the horrible that's a horrible
thing to do to a child because then
everywhere they go all the good all the
good will is false
you know there's nothing that you can do
to someone that's more terrible than to
put them in a world where all the good
will directed towards them is false
that's a terrible thing I took what I
learned about what happened in the
second world war seriously
it's like wow we can be really bad
we should do something about that
like that was unacceptable
well was it or not but how unacceptable
was it change your life unacceptable
better be
if you want it not to happen again
and it's not like it the next time it
happens
will make the previous time look like a
picnic
we're way more powerful than we were
you know when we're getting to the point
of something Jung talked about
especially near the end of his life
we're getting so powerful that each
individual is now a force of almost
unimaginable destructive power if they
so choose to be
and that's just going to
that power is going to continue to
increase
and what that means is that the degree
to which each of us has our act together
is going to be something upon which the
world increasingly Depends for its
maintenance how do I stop ruminating
these thoughts are recurring and relate
to every and any embarrassing moment I
have ever had during my lifetime I'm a
76 year old woman well oh well here's
something you could try write down
everything that you're ruminating about
I know that seems counterproductive but
like see ruminations come up
accidentally involuntarily unconsciously
whereas if you write down everything
that you're ruminating about you're
facing them voluntarily so I would say
well open up a journal or Word document
whatever and write down every time you
ruminates about something write it down
and write down every rumination you can
remember exhaustively write them all
down
that would be the first thing and the
second thing is standard behavioral
therapy practice the second thing the
next thing would be
um
write down why you think they happened
so that you get a good causal account
and then write down well what you might
have done about them then but more
importantly what you could do about them
in the future to avoid that because it
doesn't matter that something
embarrassing happened to you once what
matters is
whether or not you're likely to repeat
it in the future but my suspicions are
that even if you just
you could just start simply
write down every ruminating ruminating
thought that you have voluntarily and
and think about them in detail and write
them down in detail get every little
word down and
then you have that document and then
when you have a thought and start to
ruminate on it
then
sit down later after the ruminating
thought goes away and bring it to mind
voluntarily
so every time you have a thought you
don't want to have
later practice having that thought on
purpose and try that for about a month
and see what happens because it's often
the case that if you start thinking
about
the thoughts you're ruminating on
consciously and confront them
voluntarily that they will start to go
away you see these mass shootings all
the time and everyone does the same
thing oh how did that happen why did
that happen how can it be this way it's
like well why don't you read what they
said about why they did it and just
assume that that's the reason and if you
go if you go oh well the call of mine
kids
oh yeah I was like oh they must have
been bullied oh yes because you know the
natural response of anyone who's been
bullied is to go arm yourself to the
teeth to plot the destruction of the
entire city I think it was of Detroit to
line your entire High School Avenue with
bombs and then to go and shoot your
classmates that's what happens when
you're bullied it's like no that that's
not what happens when you're bullied
that's a stupid explanation it's shallow
beyond belief and it and it really
emerges only because people don't want
to contend with the real issue and the
Columbine kids well they were contending
with the real issue you know they
basically said quite forthrightly that
in their own arrogant estimation being
itself was corrupt and unnecessary and
it would be best if it was eradicated in
the most brutal possible way as fast as
possible and you get to places like that
if you dwell on Revenge for three or
four years in your mom's basement you
know you can go to very dark places pick
something pick something aim at it as
you move toward it you'll get wiser then
maybe your aim will change that's okay
but at least it'll change in an informed
way
it's like discipline yourself in one
dimension
see what happens
well that's exciting
and I think that's something that's open
for everyone
you can do that I shouldn't say that
because I don't believe that I think you
can find yourself in situation that's so
dire that you don't there's no escape
from it
but that doesn't matter because this
still this is the hero myth might not be
the best we have might not always work
but it's still the best we have
and the fact that it might not work
doesn't mean we should throw it away
it's still the best we have I mean
everyone dies and so we fail in some
sense
the fact that a symphony ends doesn't
mean that it wasn't worth listening to
let's say you want to fix up your house
which is actually quite a lot like
fixing yourself up which is a very
common dream metaphor yeah well the
first thing you want to do is go look
around and see what needs to be fixed
you know and this the interesting thing
about that and this is akin to what
comedians do is that as soon as you're
willing to admit comedians look at a
problem and then rise above it right
away and make a joke about it but as
soon as you're willing to admit that you
have a problem
then you're you've immediately contacted
the part of yourself that's at least
strong enough to admit that you have a
problem and so soon the act of admitting
the problem is actually the first step
to solving it yes you might say well and
it's an optimistic step because you
might say oh my God I can't admit to I
that I have a problem because what if I
can't solve it well exactly so then
maybe you won't admit to it if you do
admit to it you're simultaneously
admitting to the possibility that you
could solve it yes and then it can
actually become something that's
optimistic you can say well my life is
horrible it's like okay but I'm doing 50
things wrong well great I can fix those
things and then maybe it wouldn't be so
horrible I've watched the audiences very
carefully and listen to them
to see what resonates and and what
doesn't and
I think the
the the the the basic argument that I've
been laying out
is that
well we all have difficult lives you
know that life is characterized in in
large part by suffering there's an
inevitable element of suffering in life
I mean obviously that symbolized in
Christianity by the crucifixion which is
a very harsh symbol and
um and not only is life sorrowful
in in part but it's also touched by
malevolence and malevolence of each of
us and the malevolence of our social
Creations our societies and even in some
sense the kind of blind malevolence of
Nature and
so it's it's it's it's it's it's a
demanding
occupation to to exist as a human being
and you need
something
to sustain yourself through that it's
not optional because the the price of
existence is so high that without that
sustaining meaning
it it it corrupts you it it embedders
you and and once you're embittered
things go downhill rapidly you get
vengeful and and you get angry and and
you get destructive and there's really
no limit to that and I've been
suggesting to people that the sustaining
meaning that they can find in their life
isn't to be found through happiness
let's say because happiness doesn't work
when you're not happy when when when
when things have gone badly for you for
for even for accidental reasons but you
can find sustaining meaning and
responsibility
and you can take responsibility
for yourself
you can do that and if you take
responsibility for yourself you treat
yourself as if you're someone that's
worthy of
care and and discipline and then that
has nothing to do with being soft on
yourself
or the pursuit of pleasure any of those
things you can take responsibility for
yourself and that works and then if you
do that properly you can take
responsibility for your family and then
if you do that properly you can take
responsibility for your community and
you can continue to
burden yourself voluntarily let's say
with with a greater and greater range of
existential challenges and all that that
does is make more and more and more of
you
and that works as an antidote to the
catastrophe of Life what's the best
method to retain what you read and to be
able to use it in conversation
oh well
it's very difficult really to retain
anything without recalling it so
look if you encounter something
and then you encounter it again you can
usually recognize that you've
encountered it before that's recognition
memory so it's it's an important form of
memory it's it's it's the memory that's
associated with familiarity but it's not
the same as being able to use something
exactly it's a rather shallow form of
memory even though it's necessary
in order to be able to use something
you have to recall it this is also very
useful hint for studying like if you're
studying and you have to remember what
you want to do is study and then you
want to write down what you just learned
so you read a paragraph you close the
book and you write down what you
remember or you read a chapter and you
close the book and you write down what
you remembered or at least you sit there
and you try to remember because the way
you remember is by practicing
remembering
okay so if you're reading and you want
to use it in conversation
then you have to think about what you
read you have to put it in your own
words it's often helpful to close the
book and write it down or to associate
it with some problem that you're
currently trying to solve you have to
take the knowledge and make it your own
and then and then that alters the
structure through which you look at the
world and that changes the way that you
think so that when you have a
conversation the next time that you're
going to have the conversation in a
different way so merely reading isn't
enough you have you have to read and
think and recall and it's the act of
recalling that produces the remembering
and it's that act of remembering that
puts that material at hand for you
that's why humility is always stressed
in in great religious Traditions
humility is precisely that it's like you
have to look at why you're not so good
yeah and and you know that that has to
break down your pride to some degree and
your arrogance it's like well that's
great because if you break down your
pride and your arrogance then you're
primed to learn and you can solve your
problems so there's nothing in that it's
a bit crushing to begin with because you
might think oh my God there's really a
lot of things wrong with me yeah but at
least then you're on the on the road to
fixing them I just found out I'm having
a girl congratulations what can I do to
raise her to think for herself
and not fall into the modes of thinking
proposed by popular culture well
you can let her think for herself when
she's a kid you know what you do is so
that she practices doing that you know
um
and so that means to
consciously encourage as much autonomy
as possible so
how do you do that well let's say she's
a little kid she's three and she starts
to get interested in clothing so you lay
clothing out on the bed and you say well
you can wear this or you can wear this
you let her make autonomous decisions
you know and with kids
you don't want to let them choose from
an infinite menu you want to give them a
constrained menu but what you want to do
with your daughter is allow her to make
as many decisions as she can possibly
make as early as possible
you know and that doesn't mean that
children always know what's best for
themselves or any nonsense like that it
just means that you're going to
encourage her autonomy to every
in every
measure that you can manage that means
you're going to have to be brave and
allow her to subject herself to a
certain number of risks
so
you you you raise her to think for
herself by letting her think for herself
and and that can start that can start
quite early
um I would say when she's a teenager
she's going to fall into the modes of
thinking proposed by popular culture
because that's part of being
enculturated and socialized it's
virtually inevitable and it's even
somewhat desirable but what you hope is
that you've
you've encouraged the capacity for
autonomous thinking to a sufficient
degree that it's likely to integrate
with that more intense teenage
socialization and then re-emerge so you
get someone who comes out the other side
as an autonomous individual and that
works with boys and girls so so you know
let's I guess you do what Geppetto did
in Pinocchio is the first thing you
decide is well you don't want to raise a
puppet
you know you want to raise an autonomous
person and and then you think through
what does it mean to be an autonomous
person what sort of person do you want
your child to be what what sort of
person do you want to encourage your
child to be
and then having having
established that vision in mind that's
going to guide your choices but at least
you're making the right choices you
don't want someone who's dependent and
whiny and cringy and and and more
frightened than they need to be and
Martyr martyr like and vengeful and
malicious and manipulative and
mendacious all of those things you want
someone who can
make their own judgments and you can ask
kids what they think pretty damn early
like you have to be careful and not push
them beyond their capacity but
if you know your child you'll be able to
see what level of decision making
they're capable of engaging in and then
you would encourage them to mature as
rapidly as they can
you know and that also means that you
have to not allow yourself to fall too
in love with the
dependent and needy creature that your
infant will be to fulfill your own
emotional needs
you want to detach and and encourage to
mature as rapidly and as comprehensively
as possible and that will work
you know and
some of that some of that is
negotiation with your child you find out
what they think it's like what do you
think about this
what do you think about who should do
the work in the house how should we
split it up like they can be engaged in
the decision-making process is a very
early age
and and part of that's
that encouragement is
going to be reflected in your implicit
attitude that the child is a real person
who's capable of
imposing their will
in a realistic sense
in the world on the world and doing that
in a
competent and
excuse me competent and confident manner
I speak to my audience this seriously
and pessimistically in some sense about
part of the substructure of existence
the the Mortal side The Fragile side
but
conclude I would say that
there's more to you than there is
to what faces you and I believe that to
be true and and then I'm encouraging
people to to attempt that and then I
think part of the reason that the book
has been perhaps particularly popular
among men
is because I don't think we do a very
good job at the moment of encouraging
men we have this idea that there's
something intrinsically oppressive about
the patriarchy and about masculinity in
general and I think that's nonsense I
think that
strong honest truthful courageous men
pursuing noble goals is of great benefit
to everyone male and female alike
resentment is a key human motivation and
I would say it's I'm it's a great
teacher to to listen to your resentment
is one of the best things you can
possibly do you have to admit that it
exists first and then you have to admit
to the fantasies that it's generating
and you have to admit to what you would
regard as the way out of it so that's
all very difficult because it means
learning things about yourself that you
probably don't want to learn but
resentment only means one of two things
it means either like shut the hell up
grow up quit whining and get on with it
that's one thing it means or someone is
playing the Tyrant to you might even be
you and you have something to say and do
that you should say and do to put it to
a stop and so maybe and resentment can
show you the pathway to doing that
um
there's a meditation on resentment and
one of the one of the principles that I
extracted from that is like a resentful
person wants other people to change
and if you're resentful then your
motivations aren't trustworthy in fact
they're very very dark and that's why I
went to the extreme with people like
panzram and the Columbine killers
um
resentful people who want to change the
world are not to be trusted
what should you do instead how do you
treat your own resentment I would say
well there's a there's a great I read
this great line and then T.S Eliot play
called the cocktail party and in it this
woman comes up to a psychiatrist I think
this is in this chapter and she says you
know I'm having a really rough time of
it I'm suffering badly my life is not
going well and and then she says uh I
hope that there's something wrong with
me
and the psychiatrist says what the hell
do you mean by that and she says well
here's how I look at it there's either
something wrong with the world and I'm
just in it and that's how it is and then
like what am I going to do about that
because it's the whole world or maybe I
could be fortunate and there's something
wrong with me that's causing all this
unnecessary suffering and if I would I
could just set it right I could learn
and I could set it right
and so
well I've been thinking about that for a
very long time and I think well if your
life isn't going the way it is you know
you can find someone else to blame which
is pretty convenient for you and also
relatively easy or you could think okay
I don't like life I don't like the way
my life is unfolding
um maybe I don't like life in general
because it's tragic and and tainted with
evil
how do I know if my judgment is accurate
and the question is well have I really
done everything I possibly could to set
my life straight
because maybe I shouldn't be judging it
quality or the quality of life itself or
being itself for that matter if I
haven't done everything I possibly could
to set my life straight
well so there's a there's a task soldier
knitson who I'm a great I'm a great
admirer of social Nets and his book the
gulag archipelago was one of the things
that brought down the Soviet Union and
he said that one man who stopped lying
could bring down a tyranny and you know
he said that was some Authority I think
you could easily make the case that the
gulag archipelago is the greatest book
of the 20th century I mean there's other
contenders obviously but he said when he
was in the gulag camps you know
meditating on how the hell he got there
and he had a rough life man I mean first
of all he was on the Russian front at
the beginning of World War II and then
he was thrown in the gulag camps and
that was just the beginning of his
adventures man he had a rough life he
was in the camps he was thinking what
the hell like how that what how did I
get here what's going on and he had
Hitler and Stalin to blame right so if
you have if you need someone to blame
man Hitler and stellen that that's great
but he he that isn't what he did he said
he meditated for a while once he
realized that he might have something to
do with in some strange way with the way
things turned out for him and he said he
went over his life with a fine-tooth
comb in his memory he thought okay
where did I go wrong but by my own
judgment when when I when there was a
path in front of me when did I take the
path that I knew I shouldn't take
because you all know that right you know
sometimes you don't know if what you're
doing is good or if it's bad
it's just ignorance you just don't know
but sometimes you bloody well know and
you do the thing you know you shouldn't
do anyways that happens a lot and why do
you do that Spite is part of it
stupidity there's all sorts of reasons
but you certainly know you do it
solution thought okay well what would
happen if I took responsibility for
where I am in this concentration camp
and then I went over my whole life and
tried to figure out all the things I did
that were wrong by my own estimation
that increased the probability that I
would get here and then what would
happen if I tried to set them all right
now in the present
and that's why he wrote the gulag
archipelago and one of the consequences
of that as I said was It sped the
dissolution of the Soviet Empire so hey
that's not bad eh like you make a real
confession you really repent you you do
your Penance which is writing this book
and you completely change the
geopolitical landscape of the world it's
like and that that's worth thinking
about because it's not only
soldiernitzen who did that Nelson
Mandela did something quite similar it's
not so impossible and so the idea that
what you should do if you're feeling
resentful about the nature of being or
suffering too much for your own life
let's say is straighten the damn thing
out like seriously try it for a year
even try it for a week try not doing the
things you know you shouldn't do try not
saying the things you know to be false
and just watch what happens you might as
well give it a shot one of the things
that happens in the Mesopotamian
creation myth the enumelis is that the
gods are created they're they're the off
spring of chaos that's a good way of
thinking about it and they become very
careless and they destroy their category
system they destroy their father
essentially and Chaos comes flooding
back
and that's what happens to people who
aren't looking at things and delimiting
them properly they become apocalyptic
and do them in
so but sometimes in mythology there is
the positive
confront confronting of the god AG
Prometheus so sometimes we need to still
steal the fire sometimes we need to
challenge these orthodoxies don't we yes
absolutely I mean part part of the well
part of the death that you're describing
is actually the confrontation with a
form of tyrant like your previously
addicted self was the Tyrant over your
emergent self yes and so it's an
internal Tyrant and you said it was
predicated on a false value system
that's a false set of gods essentially
and so you had to confront that that is
a kind of death if you're seriously
suicidal
and you can tell if you are if you have
a plan like a plan that you've that
you've laid out in fantasy multiple
times if you know how you would do it
and when and where and if you fantasize
about the aftermath like if that's a
well-developed plan then you should go
talk to someone you should talk to
someone professional you should let a
friend know you should let a family
member know like you need to do that
you're at risk you're in danger under
those circumstances it's better to have
a plan you know what's the idea if you
don't have your own plan then you're the
tool of someone else's plan
so that's probably not good especially
if you don't know what their plan is
so so that's useful you could do that
as the negative emotion ramps up in
intensity the amount of time that you
construe as manageable shrinks you know
and if you're extremely depressed and
anxious then you know you may be
struggling to get through the day and
then you need
a map of what is going to constitute a
minimally acceptable day and that might
be one where you've done what you need
so that when you wake up tomorrow things
aren't worse right you have to keep up
with your obligations and your duties at
least enough so that you're not
degenerating downhill the lecture is a
form of Theater now it's a serious form
of theater but
theater can be serious you know and and
there's a see because partly what I'm
doing is I'm presenting ideas to an
audience but I'm also modeling the act
of engaging with ideas and that's the
theatrical end of it and I don't give
the same talk twice like I have my
stories and I have my collection of
things I know and I talk about but I try
to I try to do two things
um I try to in I'm always talking to
specific individuals in the audience and
so I'm having a conversation with the
audience and so that's that's part of
the dynamic element of the performance
and the other thing I'm trying to do is
to further my thinking on the topics
that I'm addressing and there is a
theatrical element to that because it's
it's like I think this the closest thing
really that it compares to is probably
stand-up comedy although I think the
routines that comedians have are
probably more well and formally
practiced than the ones that that you
know than than the than the talks that I
that I engage in I don't really think of
it as delivering a lecture to an
audience I'm trying to think about
complicated things in real time with an
audience there to participate and and to
use the audience as
an indicator of whether what I'm saying
is gripping and comprehensible it took
me a long time
pretty meant in that sort of technical
sense and it means something like this
it means what you don't know is more
important than what you know
and that's a lovely thing too then then
what you don't know can start to be your
friend you see people are very defensive
about what they know and for the reasons
we've already discussed but the thing is
you don't know enough and the re you can
tell you don't know enough because your
life is not what it could be and neither
is the life of the people around you you
just don't know enough and so what that
means is that every time you encounter
some evidence that you're ignorant
someone points it out you should be
happy about that because you think oh
you just told me how I'm wrong it's like
great like maybe I had to sift through a
lot of nonsense to get through the real
message that you're telling me but if
you could actually tell me some way that
I'm wrong and then maybe give me a hint
about how to not be wrong like that well
then I wouldn't have to be wrong like
that anymore that that would be a good
thing and and you can you can you can
embark on that Adventure by listening to
people and if you listen to people they
will tell you
they'll tell you amazing things if you
listen to them and many of those things
are little tools that you can put in
your toolkit like Batman and then you
can go out into the world and use those
tools and you don't have to fall blindly
into a pit quite as often and so the
humility element is well
do you want to be right
or do you want to be learning
and then it's deeper than that it's do
you want to be the the tyrannical King
who's already got everything figured out
or do you want to be the continually
transforming hero or fool for that
matter who's getting better all the time
and that's actually a choice you know
it's a deep choice and it's better to be
the self-transforming fool who's humble
enough to make friends with what he or
she doesn't know and to listen when
people talk and listening is a
transformative exercise like if if you
listen to the people in your life for
example if you actually listen to them
they'll tell you what's wrong with them
and how to fix it and what they want
they can't even help it if you start
listening because people are so shocked
if you actually listen to them that they
they tell you all those sorts of things
that they might not have even intended
to things they don't even know and then
you can you can work with that and so
and the other thing that's so
interesting you know now and then you
have a meaningful conversation right you
need to have a good conversation with
someone you walk with you think geez you
know what we really connect could and I
know more than I did when I came away
from that conversation and during the
conversation you're really engrossed in
it and that that that feeling of being
engrossed is a feeling of meaning and
the feeling of meaning is engendered
because you're having a transformative
conversation so your brain produces that
feeling of meaning for it says oh yeah
this is exactly where you should be
right here and now it's it's the right
place and time for you and that's a
great place to occupy and so a good
conversation where people are listening
has exactly that nature and the reason
it has that nature is because it is in
fact transformative it's one of the
truisms of of Clinical Psychology like
if you're a clinical psychologist a huge
part of what you do is just listen to
people it's like you know they come in
they're unhappy and they'd rather not be
something like that you say well why do
you think you might be unhappy and they
don't know they have some ideas and they
may have to ramble around for like a
year before they figure out why they're
unhappy they get rid of a bunch of
reasons why they thought they were
unhappy that are untrue and then you
kind of get to the heart of the problem
and then you might ask them well if you
could have what you wanted so that your
life would be okay what would that look
like then they have to ramble around a
bunch about that because they don't
really know but the listening will
straighten them out because people think
by talking and in order to think you
have to have someone to listen because
it's very hard to think hardly anyone
can think and even the people who can
think can only think about a limited
number of things but almost everybody
can talk and you can listen to yourself
talk and if someone listens to you then
well then you also have a foil for your
thoughts right because you can watch the
person when you're talking and see if
you're boring or see if you're amusing
or if you're engrossing all of those
things and so
listening that's a very good thing
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to see the
top 10 I did on Simon sinek check the
video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there you cannot have
Innovation or progress without failure
it doesn't exist and if you truly aren't
failing as you're trying to innovate
then you're probably not pushing very
hard because you haven't broken anything
you're making very very safe choices we
could never put a person on the moon
without a bunch of rockets